перша мобілізація у Росії після 1941
року за часів афганської війни Вона за
фактом йшла але офіційно не
оголошувалася у середу Володимир Путін
ймовірно щоб не викликати бурхливих
протестів населення назвав свою
мобілізацію частковою
вважаю за необхідне підтримати
пропозицію Міністерства оборони та
Генерального штабу про проведення в
Російській Федерації частковою
мобілізації
одразу у слід за Путіним по телебаченню
виступив міністр оборони Сергій Шойгу
який заявив що у ході мобілізації
призвуть 300 тисяч осіб
300 тисяч резервістів які будуть
призвані хоч і одразу сказати що це не
одноразова це та робота яка
проводитиметься планово
тим часом у Києві досить спокійно
відреагували на рішення Путіна провести
частково мобілізацію коментарі політики
у соцмережах мають радше саркастичний
характер так радник глави офісу
президента України Михайло Подоляк
написав
пішов 210 день триденної війни росіяни
які вимагали знищити Україну зрештою
отримали перше мобілізацію друге закриті
кордони блокування банківських рахунків
третє тюрму за дезертирство четверте
спецзагони для опущених у пвк все ще йде
за планом чи не так у життя чудове
почуття гумору
загальна тональність заяви які лунають з
Києва для українців мобілізації урф
нічого не міняє треба розуміти що ці так
звані резервісти вони значно гірше
готові до війни ніж та армія яка зараз
воює проти України ось ці сили До речі
які зараз залишки їх воює це десь з тих
175 тисяч які починали вторгнення в
Україну повномасштабне І це
найбоєздатніша скажімо ядро російської
армії насправді Це ж переважно
контрактники спецпризначенців чи
найманці зараз Ну і якщо вони не змогли
досягти якихось значних результатів то я
не думаю що цим
перехожих опитаних Давай на вулицях
Києва новина про мобілізацію схоже теж
не дуже схвилювала
Путін в банк пішов
У нього там великі втрати на фронті і
він пішов в банки почало в них і так ця
частково мобілізації як вона називається
скритна є давно вони по суті нічого
особо такого не сказав
Ну думаю все-таки вони визнають свою
поразкою все-таки що ми перемагаємо Ми з
оптимальним духом йдемо тільки вперед до
перемоги Ну я думаю що в них сейчас
мабуть почнуться якийсь уже протести
відносно цього
Ну а м'ясо хай приходить до нас думаю що
це
трохи як сказати нечесно бо він і в них
немає а мобілізація є дуже цікаво
виходить Тому
а Чи вплине це на хід війни бо я вірю в
Україну і не думаю що якась ще одна
кубка людей які не розуміють за що І
навіщо вони сюди йдуть
На жаль Помирати щось змінять тим часом
російські опозиційні телеграм-канали вже
розповсюджують фотографії повісток у
військкомат які почали масово отримувати
мешканці Москви та санкт-петербурга при
цьому вартість авіарейсів із цих міст до
безвізових країн станом на середу
досягла захмарних висот і навіть за
такими цінами більшість квитків уже
продано однак перехожі на вулицях москви
реагують на питання щодо можливого
відрядження на війну радше апетично ніби
з різниці Я людина проста скажуть піду
здохнемо всі хтось раніше хтось пізніше
у такі моменти завжди тривожно У тебе є
дружина діти і ти думаєш про те що якось
залишати їх не хочеться Якщо раптом щось
при цьому найбільш бойовий дух у тих
опитаних То точно не підлягає
мобілізації за віком чи статтю
це ж наші люди ми їх маємо захищати і
маємо бути єдині у всьому я вважаю що це
нормально
тим часом у Німеччині виступ Путіна
розчинили як подальшої ескалацію війни з
боку Кремля і як вияв слабкості
російського президента
для мене це ознака слабкості Україну -
Це не налякає нас це теж не повинно
лякати Ми повинні налаштуватися на
тривалий конфлікт з Росією тому нам
потрібно обговорити у полі союзників і
партнерів як ми можемо підтримати
Україну більше довший боротьбі за мир та
свободу
думку політиків поділяють також німецькі
експерти
На мою думку Путін показує ознаку
слабкості справа не лише В суті цієї
часткової мобілізації а й у тому що він
спочатку хотів вимовити промову а потім
відклав її у військовому плані справи в
Україні у росіян виглядають не найкраще
і я вважаю що ця часткова мобілізація не
допоможе йому
англійську
це поза сумнівом ознака слабкості
врешті-решт йому не довелося б іти на цю
ескалацію Якби його військові тримали
ситуацію під контролем як він того хотів
і уявляв А це явно не так невдачі
російської армії величезні вони
накопичуються у військовому плані
Україна схожа поступово притискає Росію
спиною до стіни до того ж експерти
сумніваються що це зможе змінити
ситуацію на полі бою
збільшення чисельності російських військ
на 300 тисяч солдатів це багато але
користі від цього буде не так роботу яку
являє Путін ви не можете раптово
призвати потужні підрозділи у вас просто
буде юрба людей з яких ви не зможете
швидко створити великі підрозділи також
не надто розумно впихати по кілька
солдатів То тут то там у деякі вже
існуючі підрозділи які вже
деморалізовані і можливо втратили значну
частину свого спорядження
вони не можуть з'явитися одномоментні
по-перше на 300 тисяч потрібно мати
одразу амуніцію мати озброєння мати
забезпечення зараз іде зима зимовий
формений одяг нормальної якості якого
бракує росіянам тому що не говорив і
багато чого іншого тому я думаю що це
буде знаєте отаке от підживлення окремих
напрямків
російськими силами на півночі на сході
Ну ось такими там
10-15-20 тисяч від сили досі Путін
уникав оголошення мобілізації оскільки
це не популярний крок населення І лише
критична ситуація на фронті змусила його
вдатися до цього вважають експерти це
може спричинити зростання антивоєнних
настроїв активістське спільноти у різних
російських містах уже закликають
незгодних виходити на вулиці приміром
громадський рух весна закликав у
соцмережах до масових акцій протесту
проти мобілізації назвавши її
могилізацією
досі російському керівництву вдавалося
підтримувати певну подобу нормального
життя особливо у великих містах таких як
Москва чи Петербург люди не відчували
війни з Москви та Петербурга майже не
було жертв але тепер завдяки цій
частковій мобілізації ситуація зміниться
зараз війна справді входить майже до
кожного будинку на фронт відправлять
батьків та синів а чоловіків зірвуть з
робочих місць щоб воювати в Україні нині
війну безумовно помітять у значній
частині населення Росії
експерти зауважують що слова Путіна були
скеровані також на захід він пригрозив
використанням ядерної зброї у цій
ситуації заходу Важливо не піддатися
путінському шантажу переконані експерти
ці закони а також постійні погрози що
він використовуватиме всі засоби включно
з ядерними загрозами є частиною психо
економічної війни і Путін та його режим
дуже розраховують на певні сили тут у
Німеччині а також у Франції та інших
європейських країнах які вважають що
загальна мобілізація це свого роду
кнопка натиснувши на яку Путін виграє
війну Путін зараз слабкий і я думаю що
найважливіший сигнал для всіх у
Німеччині та Європи це не лякатися цих
законів які не змінюють ситуацію у
військовому відношенні не змінюють
ситуацію для України і лише підкреслюють
що Росія є авторитарною та тоталітарною
системою зсередини
у промові Путін також підтримав
референдуми у так званих ЛНР і ДНР та на
інших окупованих Росією українських
територій псевдо голосування має
розпочатися 23 вересня західні лідери
вже заявили що не визнають їхніх
підсумків